[Music]  we brought together some of the best  investigators in Europe we are  supporting 60 high-level investigations  right now we have identified over 50,000  people smugglers in our in our database  we've identified 500 suspected vessels  that we think people smugglers are using  in in the Mediterranean as well  [Music]  in our database we could find  connections between the suspects in that  case with three other national  investigations that we're supporting  around Europe quickly identify the  international criminal syndicate that  was behind that terrible tragedy in  order that we can eventually lead to  their arrest and successful prosecution  every day do report we're working with  all Member States to try and hit these  people smugglers wherever they operate  in Europe  [Music]  you  [Music]